[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to awesome comic share one-stop
shop for everything comic book
entertainment I'm your host Walter Binet
dziak today we're talking about rogue
wanna star wars story and if it's better
or worse than Star Wars Episode 7 the
force awakens and we have a great panel
before I get to the panel let's talk
about the Facebook page because this is
very serious facebook.com slash awesome
comics show guys every single Thursday
we have exclusive videos that go up on
there we had this past week we do yes so
you want some bonus content I think you
should go ahead and like that Facebook
page
okay let's introduce the panel for today
we'll go to the right first on my right
far right
it's Heather Roose what's going on yeah
hi I'm excited to talk about rogue one
and I'm also super excited about these
sweaters I have little puffball
pokeballs
I actually went ahead and made a
tutorial so if you guys want to make
your very own ugly geek sweaters they
turn out kind of ugly and more awesome
so if you want to make your own go ahead
and like our Facebook page we'll make
sure to share a link or video to all of
that stuff that I did so that should be
really fun yes and my pal your pal mr.
Brian Porter has awesome sweater
Liyana serenity awesome it's got washes
dinosaurs my favorite part of the of the
sweaters the dinosaurs it's great stuff
and mine I mean it's always more before
we get into the comparison to force
awakens I wanted to talk about rogue one
just our impressions of it I'll give you
a spoiler warning before we get into
spoilers not talking about spoilers
quite yet so Porter what did you think
of row 1 a Star Wars story it was
awesome
like I I was excited to see it and I
thought it was gonna be good but I
wasn't like super excited and I didn't
think there's gonna be super good
blew me away on how freaking fantastic
it was it was way better than I expected
and it just it the movie was quick it
flowed awesome and like I loved it I was
great it was just a huge shock at how
amazingly good it was okay like it was
to be great yeah I was just expecting a
good you know kind of solid movie just
but I didn't think you know not being a
regular Star Wars film they'd never done
anything like this before it sounds kind
of like reserved I was like oh
could be cool but you know this not
exactly Star Wars we'll see what happens
blew me out of the water I was like
pleasantly surprised okay that's great
yeah I mean I pretty much agree with
Porter I thought it was a great movie I
wasn't quite sure what to expect going
in as well because yeah like same thing
there it was never been done before and
the force awakens was so good I was like
hey is this gonna top it how's it gonna
gel into the universe but I was
pleasantly surprised especially by the
visuals oh yeah holy cow visuals in this
movie and they even have some callbacks
to some of the original concept art from
original Star Wars Oh blew me away with
the visuals I know that they they used
the some of the original costumes from a
new hope like from this and the original
costume that's back in this movie and
then things that they added on I loved
it by the way hi I absolutely loved it I
was sitting there like jaw to the floor
most of the film like it was really
great especially the beginning was a
little slow for me personally but then
it picked up and was really like
action-packed and stuff and it was it
was really really incredible to like see
all these characters on the big screen a
lot of throwbacks but especially the
costuming they they really made this
world feel like it fits like a puzzle
piece right before a new hope like they
really really did a good job even just
the like hairstyles and facial hair of
everyone felt very very much like the
same era it felt like having gin into
the costume she wears it's it's very
like utilitarian
and not ultra like feminine I kind of
love it it's like serves a purpose we
didn't need to put her in these like
giant queen-like robes which do not get
me wrong I love Patton he's mortal but
it wouldn't make sense for this
character so she even fit and it was
nice to see some other female like small
background characters like some of the
pilots and stuff like oh women floor you
could have to two Asians in the main
like cast and not have to talk about it
so it was really cool to see some like
people of color to see some women in the
cast it was I really loved like the good
mix of characters including like there's
some really cool alien rebels in us that
we're really cool like don't even talk
English you know like not a main
character by any means but it's really
cool yeah I was expecting a lot more
character development I would say or
like story arcs we're a little bit of a
letdown personally overall yeah I mean
there are no spoilers but right I feel
like they just couldn't quite fit it all
in hmm so the cast was a bit bloated
like I feel like there's too many main
characters but it also didn't really
matter cuz it wasn't about the character
it felt more like a military procedural
drama or an espionage spy film than it
did a Star Wars film I felt like it was
a war epic right war epic almost mixed
with like a heist movie
mm-hm you know um they're they're all
fighting for this cause and we kind of
get to see like a different side to the
rebels we usually see them as like
putting them on a pedestal and being
like they're the good they're the best
the goatest of the good yeah that's
right goodness like they're they're like
so so knight in shining armor type of
people and then in this we get to see
them like in the nitty-gritty which a
couple times it went a little far I was
like really yeah like what cost are you
gonna fight for this okay but you know
we get some
that like hints of that in the original
ones I would say when they talk about it
but we don't really see it and this one
we really get to see it and then the
whole like heist of having to like go
get some stuff you don't want to give
away to it he's more than all right
let's get into spoilers now this is your
spoiler warning if you've not seen bro
on a Star Wars story yet recommendation
let's get into the nitty-gritty here is
rogue one a Star Wars story better than
Star Wars Episode 7 the force awakens
which is better which which one is a
little bit stronger which one's a little
bit weaker Heather what do you think
okay so Porter and I were saying this
earlier they're two very very different
movies it's kind of like comparing
apples and oranges but if we must
I preferred rogue one yeah a little bit
I enjoy war dramas and war stories so I
feel like maybe that's a part of what
drew me more into rogue one rather than
the force awakens it's not a huge
difference they're both great movies but
I felt like rogue one drew me in a
little bit and maybe it's because there
was a certain element to rogue one where
I felt like it was geared more towards a
adult audience which isn't a bad thing
that of the force awakens is more geared
towards a family child's movie so to
speak even though it's pg-13 but that's
a whole nother discussion but I still
felt very drawn into rogue one I would
live in that world if I could of rogue
one everything was the sets and the
visuals and the feel of it made me just
want to stay there and live there and I
did really really really love the ending
of rogue one I loved that they all died
mm-hmm that's just war that's just life
right and even though I do feel as
though the force awakens has stronger
characters but I didn't feel like that
was necessary
for rogue one because it wasn't about
the characters it was about the mission
right so whether or not the characters
were strong didn't have that big of an
impact for me I was super sucked into
the story even though I wasn't sucked
into the characters does that make sense
I got so that made me prefer wrote one
okay we disagree
I like barely man these these two are so
close in my book but again we must
decide and just by the slimmest of
margins
I prefer force awakens I really do rogue
one was excellent and there was this
great thing about seeing it and having
all these like little like kind of like
nods to the other fellows yeah or it's a
rebels or Clone Wars that were thrown in
there like even just having like gold
squadron and red squadron in there and I
was like oh my god I have to go home and
watch new hope and I did it just it sort
of refreshed my love of Star Wars yeah
it was one of those like oh man this is
super nostalgic and I can't even say
it's that install jaques since I didn't
get to go see the originals in theaters
but I feel like by seeing this I almost
feel like I was a part of it and it was
a really cool feeling that the other
ones didn't give me but the rest of it
not as much like the character
development like I was saying before the
story arcs aren't all there some of the
characters were there just and didn't
have their intentions clear and then
when they made them clear I was like
well maybe like show and don't tell
whereas I felt like with force awakens
even though there's a lot left in the
air still with Ray and we weren't told
her whole story it was it felt like an
origin story for Ray and some of the
things like I would I would say almost a
New Hope made he gave us as much
information about Luke when that one
started maybe they flushed him out a
little bit more about his parents but I
think because force awakens sort of
started this and then now we're gonna
see more where as rogue one they started
this and we're done with it and I have
so many questions it left a lot
open-ended and not necessarily in a good
way the idea mind having questions on
answers I didn't mind that I felt like
it didn't attract so many things like
wasn't about the character you don't
feel like it was making you ask the
questions like oh what about this it was
like wait no
so I Star Wars story this is something
that has a beginning middle and end
whereas the you know the rest of the
star wars are always these epochs three
parts you know trilogy is definitely and
so like this one felt more contained it
was a more complete story so that has
something like over the force awakens
because a shit-ton a question from the
force awakens but you know and then the
force awakens has like all these great
characters but so does world one I I
have a hard time picking because they're
different types of movies movies yeah I
love both of them they both have these
qualities that like I they're just
different from each other but they work
for me so well like the characters I
love the characters and force awakens
but I also really love the characters
and wrote one especially Donnie yen's
character the guy loved his I am one
with the forces cool that was so good in
the factory is he force sensitive thing
that's great about this movie though is
it doesn't follow Jedi we kind of get a
little bit of a break from the whole
like yeah that's my story
absolutely I love that we can see other
people that are just like rogues and so
I mean I mean I honestly can't pick I
can't pick I like them both for
different reasons sorry which one were
I'd rather watch I mean this is your
change I'm not this is this is initial
thing I'm not saying you have to hold
this for the rest of your life
right it's change things are gonna
changes with the sake of this
yes Nicholas which huh I choose force
awaken let me do a wakens go ahead but
it's really they're the same to me but I
have to pick something but they're the
same to me they're different movies I
like them both equally
I have to pick these you know one of the
things I liked about rogue one too is
that it was different it's usually the
force awakens is great but it's also the
originality oh I liked the originality
of rogue one
I loved the force awakens but it's kind
of a rehashing of a new hope hmm and
this was some anger yes yes so this was
something unique and different and it's
nice and fresh to see something
different in the Star Wars universe that
isn't just a rehashing this is what I'm
saying like this is why I'm so excited
about rogue one because there's so many
great characters in the Star Wars
universe and the expanding universe
which I know it's not canon but they're
still using those characters I mean it's
Ron is in rebels now and everything so I
mean that's really cool they could bring
in different characters so we can have
different movies with these side
characters that we seen in video games
and other stories and forks and comments
that we can see them have their own
movie I want to dash Rendar movie bro
okay from shadows of the empire for n64
that game is freakin awesome he's a
great character and I would love to see
a movie based on past
I don't ask I loathe Ingle I do but that
I love
but um but yeah I want to see a movie
from him I want to see I want to see a
like there's a bunch of different other
characters you can go off of and make a
movie from Kyle Katarn
from the the dark forces games Jedi
Knight the computer games yeah he's a
great character as a golden frickin
lightsaber can we see that I mean even
like a Yoda like movie I would love to
see something like that and so it would
be so far away from these other movies
because he's how many nine hundred years
old yeah and at the end of Return of the
Jedi that you could totally remove it
from these other movies so force awakens
or a rogue one a Star Wars story I
rewatched force awakens last night I
rode one on Thursday night with Porter
here so and after weighing it at first I
was like I think I like wrote one better
and then I started watching force
awakens and I care to connect with those
characters so much more I have to say
force awakens right now I mean they
could change things could get better or
worse as 8/9 come out but as of this
moment initial reaction
I love rogue one I love what they did
with it how different it is actually
like Jin's backstory and everything I
loved I thought was super smart that her
father put in the little so now that
that has been rectified and everything
people get stuff written complaining
about that so so I liked it for that and
I liked it for all these characters I
actually liked the characters even if
they didn't have the best backstory
still liked them I think a big backstory
but we felt the heart of each character
[Music]
we went through this big thing together
we succeeded we're about to die let's
have some human contact forged in fire
we're about to die let's die
together like yeah that was she just
starts knocking people yeah I connect
with the Star Wars Force awakens
characters just a little bit more I
loved kylo Ren and I want to see where a
story goes I think it's such an
interesting reverse of the story of why
he's whiny but he's like it seems like
he's got a reason to be the way he is I
mean he's so confused and conflicted I
love that there's there's an element to
him that is like sort of the reverse of
Darth Vader where you didn't you didn't
see his inner struggle and he's being
pulled to the light and a kylo Ren is be
is so hard trying to hold on to the
darkness he's realizing I was being
pulled at like he's actively pushing
away from it and that's why I love about
kylo Ren and I hope he doesn't turn back
to the light I hope he just totally goes
dark and we see him progress further and
further down that that black hole of the
dark side so that kylo Ren love I love
the hunt solo death I mean you can't
really top this a huge moment and the in
terms of emotions there's some emotional
moments in this but I mean that that got
to everybody I was dressed up as Han
Solo and I was loading of course you're
gonna relate more to the characters in
The Force awakens cuz they're setting it
up for a trilogy like they want you to
like those characters because you're
gonna be with them for a whole nother
set of money they still have the same
amount of time to build up certain
characters whether you're looking
forward to what happens right them or
not if force awakens was just if we knew
was just a standalone movie I mean what
makes sense because they're obviously
right right but I mean we got enough
where I we saw the stuff with kylo Ren
we got a little flashback with Rey and
everything and and it's so interesting
to see what's gonna happen with her then
right I don't love fan like everybody
does but I really like Finn I still
really like him I just like I like the
bromance I do like both yeah it was
funny as hell yeah a cool thing and I
just think I connected with more of
those characters and I cared more about
them not just because they were
Skywalker's or whatever right supposed
to be or anything because I
like them and I liked their stories
Ray's also very likeable apparently some
of the reshoots they did was because Jin
listen as likable so because she was I
think that's okay though that they had
to make her know the fact that she
wasn't likable I feel like they didn't
need she's a badass she's you know she
had a life and she was raised by
saw you know I mean yeah who did
everything wrong like is she biting when
raised by saw like it's pretty good so I
mean I get it she doesn't have which
doesn't have to be like cool we gotta
wrap this one up guys we I'm Way over
time but anyway what did you think of
Star Wars or world one Star Wars story I
keep mixing that up
rogue one a Star Wars story did you like
it did you think it was okay because I
know a lot of people thought it was just
okay much better
so yeah awakens what do you like better
in the comments below anything you want
so thank you for making those go ahead
and check that out which puts it up
where can we find again the social media
very quickly Heather you can find me on
twitter at how the ruse or Instagram it
a truce diana i am on twitter facebook
instagram and snapchat
i'm all over guys pota facebook.com
slash awesome porter and twitter at pork
chop 0 to 8 9 alright cool and I am
multiple AZ I can't find me on Twitter
at awesome underscore Walter and make
sure you like the Facebook page for
awesome comics facebook.com slash
awesome comic show so until next week we
got something very special for you guys
it's a there's another sniper ample so
Merry Christmas Happy Hanukkah happy
that happy Festivus whatever you
celebrate your soul celebrate celebrate
it together and see you on the neck
[Music]
[Applause]
you